[Music]
[Music]
I'll be very brief I promise on behalf
of the Council for the Arts at MIT I'd
like to welcome all of you here this
evening the as Maureen said the 1998
Eugene McDermott award was presented to
Juneau daya's last November and we're
very fortunate to have him here with us
this week for a short residency at MIT
Junot Diaz was born in the Dominican
Republic and moved to the United States
at the age of 7 much of his fiction
draws on this experience as he writes
about the clash and confluence of
cultures and that sense of dislocation
which is so much a part of the animal
immigrant experience his stories take us
back and forth between the streets of
Santo Domingo and the neighborhoods of
New Jersey where he and his family
settled
Junot Diaz rights with the jeweler's I
for detail and an unsparingly honest
voice he confronts issues of racism and
ethnic identity sexuality and family
turmoil while taking issue with the
empty promises of the American dream his
first book of fiction titled drown
received unanimous praise from critics
when it was published in 1996 he
currently teaches creative writing at
Syracuse University and as had his story
selected for the best American short
stories both in 1996 and in 1999 just a
week ago he was awarded a Guggenheim
Guggenheim Fellowship so he has lots to
celebrate please join me in welcoming
Junot Diaz
[Applause]
you're Wilding out up front they
immediately start laughing as soon as I
walk over or did I throw it actually at
home I want to thank you all did I throw
it without bad no I feel like I
sometimes [ __ ] up in public so um I
actually wanted to thank the council I
wanted to thank MIT of course for
hosting me and thank you all for coming
out on I look around I know you guys
work hard so this means a lot feel to
come out for a little bit so I wanted to
thank you all for that and also um I
wanted to thank the Eugene McDermott
people for giving me the prize that got
me Adam I got me out of Syracuse for a
couple days as you know we're getting
pounded by snow so I'm kind of joined
this little break and I also wanted to
thank Maureen she you know she drove me
around all day I know I've been like
busting her [ __ ] home so it's Ben's
like she's been like wonderful you know
cuz I'm like really bad and mean so
she's put a really good face on it and
Steve alter who came and got me today
he's been great too he's been a real
gentleman and I actually wanted to say
final words for my my dear friend I
needed to sigh who I don't think y'all
I'm I'm sure y'all don't appreciate her
as much as one should she's [ __ ]
brilliant man like I love her I really I
wish that we'd had enough loot where I
went to school so we could kidnap her
they wouldn't really you guys wouldn't
stand a chance so she's been wonderful
and I love to gossip would I need a - we
like the same writer so we get the
gossip all the time and I'm not gonna
read long I think it's always better to
keep it short so I'm just gonna read two
small stories and then I'm gonna just
open it up for just a couple of
questions there was a student I met
earlier in a class from the Bronx is he
here
yeah what's you know what after I left
you I remembered my man Street it's
called
I'm sure you know manner right do you
will matter
I [ __ ] up because I was saying it was
called mansion and then I walked down
I'm like ah you shouldn't give somebody
from the Bronx the wrong street name I
figured you went home and we're like ah
dat punk so I just thought I'd clear
that up and the first story I'm gonna
read is just from the book and then I'm
gonna read a another new story which is
sort of strange because it's kind of
fragmented and impressionistic etc etc
etc and this is just a real short one
and it it's this story came about it
actually came about from living in
Brooklyn I lived in Brooklyn for like
when I first left New Jersey I came and
lived in Brooklyn for a few years and
Brooklyn's a weird place because just
the the rate it's being gentrified so I
remember when I moved into my street it
was like mad cool you know like it was
just a nice street to live in it looked
like any place else but that like about
a year later every every time somebody
moved out of their apartment they would
like build a wall down the apartment and
make it to two apartments you know and
then like our street went from like a
normal Street with young people and then
like I remember one day we walked out
and we saw kids outside skateboarding
which is the first time in first time in
New York that you're being gentrified
when you see white kids skateboarding
you know you're [ __ ] out of luck so we
had to like move out in like six months
they raised the rent like six times so
it came out of that experience living in
Brooklyn and from living in these
apartments with really thin walls
I had a neighbor I had this neighbor
these Dominican kids and it was strange
because we knew more about the boyfriend
and the girlfriend did so they would be
like all lovey-dovey we'd see them on
the hallway they'd be you know smooching
and yundal and stuff like that and then
she would go away on a break
and the next day my man would have some
girl up at his apartment and we'd be
like oh [ __ ] and then like two days
later
two days later homegirl would come home
and he'd be like I missed you and we
could hear it through the walls so in
honor of my man I wrote this story
called boyfriend and here it goes
I should have been careful
I should have been careful with the weed
most people it just [ __ ] up me it makes
me sleepwalk and wouldn't you know I
woke up in the hallway of our building
feeling like I've been stepped on by my
high school marching band my ass would
have been there all night if the folks
in the apartment below hadn't been
having themselves a big old fight at
3:00 in the morning I was too fried to
move at least right away boyfriend was
trying to snake girlfriend saying he
needed his space and she was like
[ __ ] I'll give you all the space
you need I new boyfriend a little I saw
him at the bars and saw some of the
girls he used to bring home while she
was away he just needed more space to
Chi you can just come on in guys don't
even [ __ ] with it he just needed more
space to cheat fine he said but every
time he went for the door she got to
crying and would be like why are you
doing this to me they sounded a lot like
me and my old girlfriend Loretta but I
swore to myself that I would stop
thinking about her ass even though every
Cleopatra looking latina in the city
made me stop and wish she would come
back to me by the time boyfriend got
himself into the hallway I was already
in my apartment and girlfriend
girlfriend would not stop crying
twice she tried she must have heard me
moving around right above her and both
times I held my breath until she started
up again I followed her into the
bathroom the two of us separated by a
floor wires and some pipes and she kept
saying SF [ __ ] Pepitone and washed
her face over and over again it would
have broken my heart if it hadn't been
so damn familiar I guess I'd gotten used
to that sort of thing
I had a heart leather-like walruses got
blubber
the next day I told my boy Harold what
happened and he said too bad for her and
I said I guess so and he said if I
didn't have my own women problems I'd
say let's go comfort the widow and I
said she ain't our type and he said the
hell she ain't homegirl homegirl was too
beautiful and too high-class for a
couple of knuckleheads like us we never
saw her in a t-shirt or without jewelry
and her boyfriend Orly that there that
[ __ ] could have been a model Halliday
both could have been models which is
what they probably were considering that
I never heard word one passed between
them about a job or a [ __ ] boss
people like these were Untouchables to
me raised on some other planet and then
transplanted into my general vicinity to
remind me how bad I was living what was
worse was how much Spanish they shared
none of my girlfriends ever spoke
Spanish even Loretta of the Puerto Rican
attitudes the closest the closest thing
for me was this black chick who spent
three years in Italy she liked to talk
that [ __ ] in bed and said she'd gone
with me because I reminded her of some
of the Sicilian man she'd known which
was why I never called her again
boyfriend boyfriend came around a couple
more times that week for his things and
I guess to finish the job he was a
confident prick he listened to what she
had to say arguments that had taken her
hours to put together and then she would
sigh and say it didn't matter he needed
his space bundle she let him [ __ ] her
every time maybe hoping that it would
make him stay but you know once somebody
gets a little escape velocity going
there ain't no play in the world that
will keep them from going I would listen
to them going at it and I would be like
damn ain't nothing more shabby than
those farewell [ __ ] I know me and
Loretta had enough of those to go around
the difference was we never talked the
way these two would about our days not
even we were cool together we'd lay
there and listen to the world outside to
the loud boys the cars the pigeons and
back then I didn't have a clue what to I
didn't have a clue what she was thinking
but now I know what to pencil into all
those empty thought bubbles escape
escape these two though these two had a
thing about the bathroom each one of his
visits ended up there which was fine by
me it was where I could hear them the
best I don't know why I started
following her life but it seemed like a
good thing to do most of the time I
thought people even at their worst were
pretty [ __ ] boring the bathroom
girlfriend talked to mile-a-minute about
her day how she saw a fistfight on the C
train and how somebody liked her
necklace and boyfriend with his smooth
Barry White voice just kept going yeah
yeah yeah they'd showered together and
if she wasn't talking she was going down
on him all you would hear down there was
the water smacking the bottom of the tub
and him going yeah yeah he wasn't
sticking around though that was obvious
he was one of those dark-skinned
smooth-faced brothers that women kill
for and I knew for a fact haven't seen
his ass in action at the local spots
that he liked to get over on the white
girls she didn't know nothing about his
little Rico suave routine it woulda
wrecked her I used to think those were
the body'll rules
Latinos and blacks in whites out a place
we down cats weren't supposed to go but
love teaches you it breaks your hmm but
love teaches you it clears your head of
any rules
Loretta's new boyfriend was Italian and
walked on worked on Wall Street when she
told me about him we were still going
out we were on the promenade
and she said to me I like him he's a
hard worker and no amount of heart
leather could stop something like that
from hurting after one of their showers
boyfriend never came back no phone calls
no nothing she called a lot of her
friends one she hadn't spoken to in the
longest I survived through my boys I
didn't have to call out for help
it was easy for them to say forget her
sell out ass that's not the sort of
woman you need look how light you are no
doubt she was already shopping for the
lightest mostly girlfriend spent her
time crying either in bathroom or in
front of the TV and I spent my time
listening and calling around for a job
or smoking or drinking a bottle of rum
and two sixes of presidenta a week and
one night one night I got the cojones to
ask her up for cafe which was mighty
manipulative of me she hadn't had much
human contact the whole month except
with the delivery guy from the Japanese
restaurant
a Colombian dude I always said hi to so
what the hell was she gonna say to me no
she seemed she seemed glad to hear my
name and when she threw open the door I
was surprised to see her looking smart
and watchful she said she'd be right up
and when she sat down across from me at
the kitchen table she had on a makeup
and a rose gold necklace you have a lot
more light in your apartment than I do
she said which was a nice call about all
I had in the apartment was light I
played I played I played andres jimenez
for her and then we drank a pot of cafe
el pico I told her nothing but the best
we didn't have much to talk about she
was depressed and tired and I had the
worst gasp of my life twice I had to
excuse myself twice in an hour she must
have thought that bizarre as hell but
both times I came out of the bathroom
she was staring deeply into her coffee
the way the fortune tellers will do
back on the island crying all the time
had made her more beautiful grief will
do that sometimes not for me Loretta had
been gone now for months and I still
look like [ __ ]
having girlfriend in the apartment only
made me feel shabby er she picked up a
cheap seed from a crack in the table and
she smiled do you smoke I asked it makes
me break out she said it makes me
sleepwalk honey will stop that she said
it's an old Caribbean cure I had a deal
who would sleepwalk at 1tsp of night
took it out of him I never tried the
honey and she never came back whenever I
saw her on the stairs we would trade
highs but she's never slowed down to
talk never gave a smile or any other
kind of encouragement I took that as a
hint at the end of the month she got her
hair cut short no more straighteners no
more science fiction combs I like that I
told her I was coming back from the
liquor store and she was on her way out
with a woman friend I like that it makes
you look fierce
she smiled that's exactly what I wanted
thank you
I keep I keep waiting for that boyfriend
or write me a letter you know on the
real though
hmm I always think this takes longer
than I look at my watch and realize oh I
must go on so I used to go throw your
perspective young writers you know you I
used to go see other writers you know
you would go to their readings and the
majority of them were absolutely
unbearable because so many of them would
read for like 59 minutes and you could
feel your beard growing so I had this
thing I always promised myself to keep
it as short as possible this is a story
is this something I was sort of working
on this cycle of stories come on in nah
I was working on the cycle of stories um
and it was kind of strange because once
again I was sort of like dealing with
people dating and their relationship and
I was moving through this this life of a
fictional a fictional Dominican cat and
I was like it was sort of strange
because I was moving through like all
the relationships this guy had in his
entire life from the time when he was
like in second grade and some girl was
like me and my girlfriend want to date
you
you know to the time where he's sort of
telling this story from his mother's
basement and all his like Romeo days are
burnt out and he's now living with his
mother you know like so many men I know
living with their mom so he sorted down
in the basement like writing his little
thing and so this comes out of that
section and it's this and it was weird
because in the book it's like I don't
know I'm always like twisting the knife
and brothers in a way cuz I'm one of
them and it's good to like be so we're
talking about the like I grew up with
Cubans and I love that term I love that
almost that cultural pattern out
krithika with so many of them bring from
the island self-criticism I like adore
that [ __ ] so I was writing this thing
about like when I we were young my
friends were young and they were all all
my friends we were all like wild it out
on white girls you know there was like
this obsession and all the cats thought
they were better-looking than sisters
you know and so much of it was like
weird-ass self-hatred well maybe
somebody you don't know what I'm talking
about but [ __ ] it
so I took this segment out of that kind
of perverse stuff and and that's where
it comes from and it's a short called
Flocka and you'll have to bear with me
because it's it's something it's
something not only is it something new
but I'm also working with a style where
lately I've been like fragmenting [ __ ]
which means that it makes a lot sense
less sense than it should
good luck flakka you're left
I used to drift when you were tired or
upset it's looking for a way out you
used to say and those days we saw each
other it fluttered and rolled and you
had to put your finger over it to stop
it
you were doing this when I woke up and
found you on the edge of my chair you
were still in your teachers uniform but
your jacket was off and enough buttons
were open on your blouse to show me the
black bra that I had bought you and the
freckles on your chest we didn't know it
was the last days what we should have I
just got here you said and I looked out
where you parked your Saturn go roll up
them windows I said I'm not gonna be
here long you said someone's gonna steal
it I'm almost ready to go you stayed in
your chair and I knew better than to
move closer you had an elaborate system
that you thought would keep us out of
bed you sat on the other side of the
room you didn't let me crack your
knuckles and you never stayed more than
15 minutes it never worked I brought you
guys some dinner you said I was making
lasagna for my class so I bought the
leftover
my room back then was small and hot and
you never wanted to be in there it's
like being inside of a sock you've said
and anytime the boys were away we slept
in their living room out on the rug your
long hair was making you sweat and
finally you took your hand away from
your eye you hadn't stopped talking
today I was given a new student her
mother told me to be careful with her
because she had because she had the
sight and I said the sight and she said
and you said the sight I asked the
signora if the sight helped her in
school and she said no not really but
it's helped me with the numbers a few
times I know I knew I was supposed to
laugh but I stared outside instead where
a mitten shaped leaf had stuck to your
windshield you stood besides me when I
first saw you in our joys class and then
at Jim I knew I'd call you Flocka and if
you'd been Dominican my neighbors would
have worried about you and brought you
plates of food to my door heaps of
plátano and yuca smothered in Kassel
frito
flakka even though your name was
Veronica no boys will be here soon I
said maybe you should roll up your
windows I'm going now you said and you
put your hand back over your eye - I
remember the boys keeping an eye on me
because they were convinced that I was
gonna flip out they figured two years
ain't no small thing even though that
entire time I never claimed you but what
was nuts was that I felt fine
I felt like summer had opened up shop
inside of me and I told the boys this
was the best decision that I've ever
made you can't be [ __ ] with white
girls all your life and they looked at
me like I had a hole in my head after
you dropped me off that night the old
man and stinky wanted to know what the
[ __ ] I was thinking and I said I'm
thinking we should go out tonight I'm
thinking I gotta find me a sister soon
three I remember
we met in class you never spoke but I
did all the time and once you looked at
me and I looked at you and you turned so
red even the professor noticed you were
white trash from outside of Patterson
and it showed in your no fashion sense
and you dated [ __ ] a lot I said you
had a thing about us and you said angry
no I do not and I remember you used to
offer me rides home in your Saturn and I
remember the third time I accepted and
our hands touched in the front seat
little fugitives
for I wasn't supposed to get sere it
wasn't supposed to get serious between
us I can't see us getting married or
nothing and you nodded your head and
said you understood then we [ __ ] so
that we could pretend that nothing
hurtful had just happened this was like
our fifth time together and you got
dressed in a black sheath and a pair of
Mexican sandals and you said I could
call you when I wanted but that you
wouldn't call me you have to decide
where and when you said if you leave it
up to me I want to see you every day at
least you were honest which is more than
I can say for a lot of people who
pretend to meet who pretend to be mad
independent and aren't weekdays I never
called you didn't even miss you I had my
boys and my job to keep me busy but
Friday inside of the nights when I
didn't meet anybody at the clubs I
called those days none of us wanted to
go to bed alone and I wasn't no
different we talked until the silences
were long until finally you asked do you
want to see me you made me say yes I
want to see you and while I waited for
you I would tell the boys it's just sex
you know nothing more and you would come
with a change of clothes and a pan so
you could make us breakfast maybe
cookies you would bake for your class
and the boys would find you in the
morning in one of my shirts and at first
they didn't complain because they
figured you would just go away like the
other white girls who had passed through
the house by the time they started
saying something it was late wasn't it
five
you wanted to go somewhere so I took us
out to spruce run we'd both been there
as children you could remember the years
even the months but the closest thing
the closest I came to was back when I
was young look at the Queen Anne's lace
you said you were leaning out the window
in the night air and I had my hair on
your butt I had my hand on your back
just in case what did your family do
here you asked I looked at the night
water we had barbecues Dominican
barbecues my father didn't know how to
but he insisted he would cook up this
red sauce that he'd splatter on two
lettuce and then he'd invite complete
strangers over to eat with us it was a
horrible I wore an eye patch when I was
a kid you said maybe we met out here and
fell in love of a bad barbecue and I
said I doubt it and you said I'm just
saying you know maybe 5,000 years ago we
were together and you said 5,000 years
ago I was in Denmark and I said that's
true and about half of me was in Africa
and you said doing what and I said
farming I guess because that's what
everybody does everywhere maybe we were
together some other time and I said I
can't think when you tried not to look
at me maybe five million years ago
and I said people weren't even people
back then that night you lay a bet that
night you lay in bed awake and listen to
the ambulance tear down our street you
were hot from something your cheek could
have kept my room warm for a week and I
didn't know how you stood the heat of
yourself of your breasts of your face I
almost couldn't touch you and out of
nowhere you said I love you for whatever
that's worth six some nights I can't
sleep and some nights I pull on my
sneakers and run these are the only
times I break two miles when there's no
traffic and the halogens turn everything
the color of foil and fire up every bit
of moisture that's on the car
I run down and around the memorial homes
along George Street past Roop where the
Camelot stands boarded and burned I stay
up entire nights and when the old man
comes home from UPS I'm noting down the
times the trains arrived from Princeton
Junction you can hear them breaking from
our living room a Nash just south of my
heart and I think this staying up means
something but the old man
hears me and laughs he's a brother who
believes in the practical and hardwood
floors and paperclips
you need another job he says and he
shows me his bitten up hands a good one
that's what this is about
you need something that will give you
dreams you can't sleep without dreams
right now you're just all out six last
section we went back to spruce run once
more do you remember when the fight
seemed to go on and on and everyone
ended with us in bed tearing at each
other like maybe that could change
anything in a couple of months you'd be
seeing someone else and I would too she
was no darker than you but she watched
her panties in the shower and had hair
like a sea of little poo nose and the
first time you saw us you turned around
and boarded a bus I knew you didn't have
to take that second trip I stood on the
beach and watch you wade out watched you
rub the lake on your skinny arms and
neck
both of us were hungover and I didn't
want any of me wet there's a cure in the
waters you said the priest announced
that it's service you were saving some
in a bottle for your cousin with
leukemia and your aunt with the bad
heart you had on a bikini bottom and a
t-shirt and there was a mist sifting
down over the water lacing the trees you
went out to your waist and stopped I was
staring at you and you were staring at
me and right then it was something sort
of like love wasn't it that night you
came into my bed too thin to be believed
and when I tried to kiss you you put
your hand across my chest wait you said
downstairs the boys were watching TV and
screaming you
let the water dribble out of your mouth
and it was cold you reached my knee
before you had to refill from the bottle
I listen to your breathing how slight it
was and listen to the sound the water
made in the bottle you whispered my full
name and I remember how the next morning
you were gone completely gone and
nothing in my bed or in my house could
have proven otherwise and that's that
for that one
[Applause]
have I done enough okay
it's weird cuz the city second the
second story is like is more internal
and lately I've been writing these more
internal things that end up being kind
of dull to listen to so you know you got
to deal with it though um do you have
any questions up couldn't wait formal
training could you elaborate exactly
okay thank you
yeah um no thank you for your question
it was I had I had started writing when
I was like a like a junior or senior and
undergraduate and I was accepted into an
MFA I applied to like five of them
because like I couldn't afford more than
five and I got denied everywhere but
Cornell which was funny because Cornell
was like the only quote/unquote good
school I applied to so it shows you how
[ __ ] arbitrary this [ __ ] is you know I
mean I didn't kid myself I got in I used
to be like I didn't accept I didn't get
accepted to Vermont Mountain College you
know just them so and I went there for
my MFA you know but mostly I was telling
some other students before I mean I
really wild it out in my MFA cuz mostly
I was a community organizer and so when
we got when I got there I came in it was
back when Cornell grad school was still
letting in kids from state schools and
so they like accidentally let a bunch of
us in from New Jersey who all knew each
other and none of us went to class and
we just wild it out for the Latino and
black community and so it was only to
like my senior year that I really
started to take it seriously
yeah I mean we say it at home it's like
were too sweaty that it was just a
complete accident I mean I published one
story I had been in graduate school
after three years I hadn't sent in a
story anywhere and hey I had gone to see
my chair and she was like because you
know if you do a lot of activism which
we'll talk about in a minute you're more
than likely to be like despised by
everyone in your department and so I had
done all this activism and one of it was
critiquing the English department you
know and so we like really rammed it to
the English department you know and so
because a lot of us were sitting on
these committees and so we went berserk
on them you know and what happened was
we forced them to hire two faculty in
the English department on doing u.s.
Latino Studies you know we just like
screwed and we got Elena MIT every time
want this in there and we got somebody
in the ph.d program and so it was like
really a big success for us and then I
went to my chair to get her to sign off
on me and she was like I'm not signing
it [ __ ] you and so and then I knew I had
to leave because if they don't sign off
you might as well go home
so I was on my I said [ __ ] I'm doomed
and I had to defend in any stories out
and so I sent my first story out and it
was like talk about ancestral you know
looking out because the first door I
sent out was published accepted and
published by story magazine and I was
telling the other students before they
were like then story was like do you
have another one and I sent them another
one and they were like okay we like this
one too and so and then like I was
telling the students another class of
students that was just like you know I
was like okay so I've made all of $500
on two stories you know I got to go home
now and what ended up happening was I
had gone home and was making photocopies
and a few months into that an agent
called and she was like oh I like your
stories
I'd like to represent you and I was like
okay she was like you don't want to meet
me I'm like not really desperate so and
then like a few months later after that
she was like oh by the way she called me
at work they used to think I was working
at Pfizer Pharmaceuticals they used to
think I didn't speak English I was so
sullen I wouldn't speak to anybody they
would just like give me photocopies to
make you know
so I was making photocopies and homegirl
called me she was like oh I just sold
your book quit and so that was that you
know it sounds like a fancy funny story
but what's funny about that story is
that like I don't [ __ ] kid myself
it's like you know it's like the lottery
because every one of us who make it like
this that actually means a thousand
other young writers of color didn't make
it you know because it's like a
selection process which definitely
doesn't favor us so my friends we were
all like yeah this is great it's nice to
eat but at the same time we knew every
one of us who gets one of these
positions locks out another twenty
people and that's not something to be
all cheery about next question right
here do we have any other Dominicans
here like raise your hand all right
could you answer that question for me
yeah why don't you try presentable back
in Jersey back home I came here to
Washington and we gave me a curve and it
was okay it was all right as long as I
kept track though when Indy are the
racetrack just to use that as a metaphor
just it's a very symbolic view of old
women ever seen in VR if I were to leave
the house and not straight
straighten your hair because I know
mm-hmm there was another hand if
somebody else want to try that one no oh
yeah I mean I think you know some people
mingle isn't very different from some of
the you know communities we have in the
United States like Negro phobia is just
absolutely rampant you know and I think
that like people don't like to talk
about it but the level of safe I mean
the level of self-hatred that I
encounter inside the omegle has a
perfect analog in the United States you
know as a perfect analog so when people
like when I hear a lot of people trying
to other the Caribbean and say things
are worse in the Caribbean I'm always
like worse than what you know like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about like it's
like such a weird question because it's
like worse than what like what's your
standard and so I know that when it was
intense because when we were in Santo
Domingo you know there was like I mean
in my community where I grew up like I
grew up in a I mean my name is a
testament to that I grew up in a
Dominican and Haitian community and I
was probably the lightest skin person
they'd seen in 500 years you know they
were so excited they produced me
everybody was just like my goodness we
worked so hard you know and it was very
clear it was so very clear the it was
just so very clear on the island of
things that were attributed to us like
it didn't matter how [ __ ] up ugly I
was people were like Oh Don cute I'm
like the Oh bug in but then we came to
the United States and we noticed
something even worse is that um the
United States everyone but the United
States I guess their racial measurements
are at the millimeter wave so that for
example my older brother is lighter than
me and when we went to school people
used to like throw [ __ ] at me and boo me
and my brother would come in they'd be
like oh he's got straight hair and no
signs of [ __ ] tude so I wasn't sure
what the difference was
well I mean I kind of got lucky because
I grew up with I mean I grew up with a
lot of sisters like women in my family
and they were real good at bashing it
out of us in our heads so by the time I
got to writing I had already quit uncle
resolved these issues most of them in my
head you know and so what I tend to do
in my what I tend to do when my work is
just torture people who haven't owned oh
it's a whole crew of evil Dominicans
chief oh I absolutely adore another
question
experience like one other did you have
any influences from American yeah I mean
what well for me was like I mean period
Thomas is down these mean streets is
like you know it's one of those founding
texts right and it was definitely one of
the earliest Caribbean Latino texts to
like do some good things like talk about
race etc etc but there was also some
really like wild [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
unreconstructed like just questioning
misogyny and like you know like just
wildness and so it was a real important
thing important text for me to read but
I was much more affected by a lot of the
women writers like Christina Garcia and
Sandra Cisneros and people who were
about 50 times as telling another class
were about us writers always picked like
well some of us pick better parents than
we are you know and so it's like for me
it was like 20 Morrison was a huge
influence oh yeah a brother from DC
called Edward P Jones remarkable short
story writer probably one of the most
underrated short story writers in the
country and he wrote a short story book
called lost in the city which the entire
book was set in Washington DC and he
just it was just remarkable where he
organized this collection around DC
geographically and that was just so dope
because you know most of the kids I knew
from New Jersey didn't want to use New
Jersey as background for anything
because New York has a way of erasing
you know everybody I know from New
Jersey they live one week in New Jersey
they're like yeah I'm from the Bronx my
old [ __ ] please you know what are you
talking about I saw you it's Spotswood
you clown other questions want to get to
some of the political issues in New York
in New Jersey they just had the skin
about profile and you know
cosmically besides these kind of things
gonna come up you're writing effective
hmm I mean I was actually interested in
asking like we were talking earlier in
other class about the Mumia abu-jamal
case our people organized on this campus
for that huh I did it in high school
social justice
just recently there were posters up for
the next round April yeah see I'm
disappointed in you guys I know you
should be I know you work hard but we
have the Mumia abu-jamal March on in
Philadelphia we all know he's on death
row we all know that he's an ex black
panther an important anti-police
brutality activists and a member of like
I don't know what of our I think just a
little me was very important it was
framed for you know thank you see we've
got someone who brought it I'm glad
that's there I didn't even see that and
you know the rally is April 24 from
Philadelphia and some of you students
should like organize to take some buses
down there so I'm MIT could have a
contingency and that's like my plug for
politics is to try to get people to
organize cuz we organized Syracuse
recently and we got like four buses
going down there and Syracuse students
are about nothing you know I love them
to death but they ain't about [ __ ] so if
we can get them to go with Lucien books
in Harvard Square there are groups in
the city but mighty needs some buses I
want to see your guy when I'm at the
rally smoking up I want to see some of
you guys
watch the news like I think i'ma do
people know the auto shooting that's how
many people know how many people don't
know the Diablo shooting raise your hand
you're Wilding what happens here now if
I tell you that
mallamma doobie ah Louis is the cat who
in New York City was shot 41 times by
the police yes now you know yeah that's
bad so dangers have it too other
questions or comments or beef you want
to roll into a front here that will move
back teachings I mean I always felt a
certain missionary zeal about teaching
you know cuz like we were you know we
used to gripe all the time about not
having any professors of color and so
for me that's like really important to
like get in there and work with my
students and do like not just be in the
classroom the do organizing work you
know and that's cool and getting
students prepared for grad school like I
mean our big thing is to get our
undergrads prepared for grad school like
you know when we were grad students at
Cornell we each year the grad students
the Latino and black grad students like
dedicated themselves to producing ten
grad students every year so we placed
ten students and grad schools you know
and that was just [ __ ] we did on the
side and I think that's so important
because one of the failings you know I
don't want to sound like too much like
like I drink too much but I feel like if
anything the failings of of some of the
movements that came out of the 60s and
70s was some of the weird ownership
issues that came out where mentorship is
a problem you know you tend not to see
really good mentorship from one
generation to the next like you don't
you know like I didn't see it I didn't
see a lot of these older activists
reaching out to young people to have
these young people train them to replace
them what they wanted will followers
you know they weren't training anybody
to replace anybody you know and so
that's why I think teaching is really
important I find it to be like we need
to place people in grad school you know
and other things there's people who
don't aren't grad school orientated we
need to play some in really good
community jobs and like get people going
and we got it the attrition rate at
universities I don't know how the Latino
and black student attrition rate is here
but when I was a Cornell was at the
highest in the country
you know what attrition rate is y'all
plug in you're supposed to be the smart
students that's attrition rate it's when
like students drop out you know so we
had at Cornell we had the Latino and
black students were dropping out of
Cornell with an average grade point of a
C so that meant they weren't failing out
they were cold bolting you know they
were just breaking loose and so we were
trying to figure out ways to stop that
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah there were some
okay
[Music]
so speak to some of the American tension
in that story yeah a pissant commingle
is called Yunior and east I'll
accommodate these styles one of my boys
back inside omegle he drives a cab and
he was always like he'll pull me in a
[ __ ] story yeah yeah so it was cool
dude because I got in Santo Domingo for
part of the book tour and you know we
had a radio interview and if you think
this country has class problems santo
domingo it's like ruled by oligarchical
elites so you can't imagine the class
problems there so you know we were on
the radio and we were wild and out on
the radio and all the all the ex-commies
and left-wing people were calling up and
they were just like you know [ __ ] the
rich people and halfway through all this
stuff my friend
Easter dial called me from his cab phone
and he was like you somebody ate my face
in your story
so I said come on now was it yep yeah
sure the most important thing is to I
mean we came to college again we we were
really evil because we had been trained
at Rutgers which is a very active school
you know and so we came in and we had
law students and we had accounting
students we had all sorts of students
and the first thing we dissolved was
this artificial separation between grad
students and undergrads so we just
started wild and out and going to the
undergrad meetings and shutting our
[ __ ] mouths so we would never speak
during the undergrad meetings we just
let them run things and if they needed
any of our help we would do it and then
we would start offering just services we
would start being like ill if anybody's
interested in grad school anybody wants
to talk about it and the first thing is
you got to physically be there for your
students you know like this old like
just show up and try to help him out
that's [ __ ] I mean so much of so
much of what we do as activists and
flows across interpersonal relationships
and that was our most important thing
was to break down those walls you know
and the next thing we did was we would
start targeting students that we thought
were really [ __ ] smart and shunting
them off to classes of our peers and
friends so my friend Paula was a PhD in
history or English and we would be like
yo you know you got this undergrad kid
running around he should be in one of
your classes you know and the same thing
we would be like we would just tamp
ourselves out during our office hours
all of us would give our office hours
out and it would be like open paper
writing stuff you could bring any papers
through and we would work on them for
you you know so these kids would be
funny because my other kids would be
waiting to meet me from a real class and
these kids would just break in and I
tell my other students I'm like oh this
is a very important meeting
and and that really helps and I know
that sounds kind of stupid but I mean
what kind of Blockheads so we weren't
trying to do no master Theory our theory
was if we put ourselves out there you
know people are gonna respond to that
yeah
yeah I mean that's a nice question thank
you but I'm not so sure and like who
want to talk about I mean I came from
some of us here my my parents and my
grandparents were farmers you know and
so farmers are funny because they don't
plan on anything you know and I think
part of that was given to us like we
don't I've never seen anybody my family
dream longer than their arm and it's not
a great thing I mean I actually don't
recommend it highly because I mean it
makes us very blinkered in some ways and
I mean I don't want to just attribute it
to it some family upbringing it could
have just been something in our side so
I'm like really guarded by that because
I'm always convinced like a meteor is
gonna hit em high like car or something
you know so I mean one of the things I
just want to keep doing is just keep
doing organizational work and and also
like it's important for us to do any of
us who can write to do all kinds of
writing so you know all kinds no matter
what genre it is I think we have to tear
it up like I'm sort of mad that some of
our other writers or critical literary
haven't just tackled every genre they
can possibly tackle you know which means
for like I think Tony Morrison needs to
write a horror book you know I'm a rail
just to mess up with these boundaries
you know if I stick around long enough
I'd like to do some of that work yeah
okay
yeah I'm writing a novel and I'm not
gonna tell you the title of it because
I'm I'm absolutely convinced by say the
title of it that's when the meteor hits
they're like well I'll tell you the
first section is from a film do you know
this film exterminating angel anyway
when I was a kid
my father was a real film buff for this
hick and he was talking about this film
exterminating angel and so the kids are
like exterminating angel word up you're
like you're ready to see this nonsense
you know and then it turns out to be
some buñuel film or people to sit around
and talk so it was not fun and so the
first section is called exterminating
angel and what it's about it's it's this
insane absolutely insane book about a
new minority group there then there's
like a new minority group in the United
States and it's actually based off of an
Octavia Butler story and in blood child
a really wonderful story where she
imagines people with this illness who
are like discriminated against so I just
took that one further and imagine an
entirely new group of minority group and
everybody calls the Mules because
they're sterile and it's just a real
simple story about this guy named Lou
settle who he like he's in an
underground railroad and he just spends
his time smuggling mules out of the
country and it's it's a United States
now except that none of the civil rights
legislation ever passed instead there
was in 68 I was reading these the
National Security Agency these I was a
historian so I was into this stuff and I
was reading all this stuff from the
National Security Agency and they had
prepared in 68 if there had been mass
scale rioting that they would
incarcerate 10 to 15% of the black and
Latino population and put them in huge
prison camps and declare a state of
emergency and so I thought these
documents are really interesting finding
them so what I was going to do was
imagine a United States where none of
the civil rights legislation was
instead of a state of emergency was
declared and you know the plan went
through and this is 50 years later when
the state of emergency has continues to
be you know and these characters are
like living in this world and it's about
this guy named Lou Chow and his beloved
girlfriend yaz and like both of them are
sort of conductors and they both hate
each other and are pissed off and it's
about their life you know and what I'm
trying to do is to take I know this
sounds kind of crazy but it's kind of
like cut and paste because I'm trying to
do is take stuff out of like the common
culture you know like when people talk
about for example during the Vietnam War
experimentations done on soldiers like I
love that kind of folk history and so
what I'm doing is I'm just taking this
folk history and just pretending it's
all real I notice on the berserk
good luck plenty of good luck I'm sorry
I'm gonna get this and then
I mean I think the union and the lava
character
I believe some of me my brother you know
and so the union character tends to be
the main narrator but I mean life is
stranger than fiction so I mean I had to
leave a lot of stuff out and change a
lot of things so I wouldn't exactly say
Union was me ever I mean my mother
always answers that question the best
because when she read the book in
Spanish she was always like you know I'm
a lot funnier than this woman and I'm
like no no it's like writing poetry
doesn't those are really like important
forms I have no talent or interest in
thank you though and then back there and
then here and then okay
I was wondering that is their analog you
see between you might know better than
me in a sense because I think that I
mean I think I mean I don't know I guess
what troubles me most about we want to
talk about aesthetic I think the debate
that's happening now amongst the young
writers I know is that there's a small
group of us who like think it's good to
kind of write unruly stuff and to be
political in our lives you know and then
there's another huge group of young
writers who they just want to be
celebrities you know it's all about
feeding at the trough they're like it's
like a bunch of pigs eating at the
trough and they're like don't make too
much too much noise you'll interrupt the
feeding you know and so I feel like
these one of the I mean I I think just
some old stuff hasn't been resolved yet
I mean I find so many writers I go to
writers conferences a lot you get
invited and these writers who write very
interesting complicated things where you
think they're very interested in
complicated and they start talking and
they say some wild dangerous things you
know and you find yourself like you I
mean there's writers who I was at a
conference recently with a bunch of
quote-unquote very famous established
black writers and it was painful to
behold you know because the entire time
these quote-unquote famous black writers
all they wanted to talk about was white
people and I was just like you're an
idiot like that conversation is played
out it's about time for communities to
start speaking to each other you know
like I mean the black and Latino
community hasn't even begun the dialyze
it needs to have I mean the communities
of color needs to start dialogue in with
each other in ways that have never
happened before
like right now everything a lot of these
writers just they perform their little
shucking and jiving under a white gaze
and I think that that's really foolish
because every voice should be equal and
if every voice is equal then first we
need to have a conversation with each of
us and every fifth round we'll have a
conversation with the quote/unquote
white community you know but first I'd
like to see some other conversations
occurring through their hand they're
open oh I'm sorry you would and then I'm
sure out that dissed you before but
yeah I mean prepare preparation is tough
I think some of you by now have mastered
this kind of like concentration or focus
you need to you wouldn't be here looking
at me right now I mean and part of it
comes with I mean I was telling in
earlier classes I have to do it first
thing in the morning once I start
interacting with people it's finished
then I just want to have fun you know
I'm like a social person but the other
thing is that I know this sounds corny
but it's like to appreciate the fact
that like I mean my mother watched my
mother cleans toilets you know that's
her job and so I'm like okay you know
she didn't clean toilets so I could
write some old blah blah you know some
old [ __ ] nonsense and I feel like
that for me is something that really
helps me get ready to start writing it's
like think about the old lady and then
I'm like okay time to get going you know
the cures you up mean your hand was up
when you when you left to go do your
schooling and get everything done how
did you deal
[Music]
yeah no it doesn't make sense but I mean
being an immigrant you get great lessons
and leaving your community you know and
it's not always leaving like I mean some
of us feel no connection to communities
and I'm like cool but those are not
really the people I'm talking to in a
way like I feel like if you feel a real
connection to a community like again are
the community I belong to isn't
suffering the sort of things that's
suffering and that it's being put on it
so that I could go to school and feel
real guilty you know like it didn't want
me I mean I know this sounds grandiose
and full of [ __ ] and idealistic but I
really believe this stuff it's kind of
berserk I'm like a sucker I think I'll
wake up one day but I really believe
this stuff I was like you know they
didn't send me to be a [ __ ] clown you
know and that was a real serious
business for me like they were just like
go and do good and don't come back with
some old silliness and that helps you
know but that doesn't mean it's not
there I know the first year when I was
at Cornell I was a wild drunk you know
all I did was drink drink drink drink
drink drink because I missed home really
bad and I felt like I didn't even know
what the hell I was doing and so I don't
think it's really easy I think like a
lot of us will leave home you know it's
good to have friends
I think it's great beacon great and
still niche you know kind of
multitasking writing you're also
galvanizing
and just for the stuff that came out
before hey how do you manage to watch to
say the evening news every night and
just keep that energy and keep that
idealism that you have going I mean what
keeps you fighting I guess just because
there's some when you look around
yeah but I mean think what am I really
doing like nobody's really beating me
with a chain I think that's really tough
you know and I don't end up in abuse
shelters that's like really tough you
know I mean what I'm and I'm not like
really all that influential outside of
this room ain't nobody know who the [ __ ]
I am and most of you here don't even
know who the [ __ ] I am so I mean I make
photocopies for four Mumia abu-jamal
things and you know I go to meetings for
anti police brutality that doesn't take
much time for me you know so I'm pretty
much as a grunt I'm great at making
photocopies you know and so again you
just pick your small stuff and do them
and it's not like I'm all that
successful you know I should have had
two books out by now you know if I had
dedicated myself to my writing I have
people who who we came up together and
you know they're gonna be happier people
guarantee it because they're just sit at
home and write and they're already on
book three you know and so that's it you
feel it you know you feel it when your
friends send you your third book and
you're still out on the street getting
spit on by cops you're like oh this
doesn't amount to much yeah so
you know that's like you know Toni
Morrison's I love that influential essay
of hers which he talks about how like
you know well I'm not gonna get Tony but
I love Tony but like for me it just took
somebody you know somebody said somebody
set it straight in a really good way and
again you have to be personally ready
you know this is not like some old New
Age [ __ ] but for me I was just like
drinking and getting into fights I was
stupid because I'm like this little nerd
kid but I had like I had for years and
years and years been a boxer so I would
be like hurt you know
so that was just like an idiot and one
day somebody was just like some woman I
never even knew you know I don't even
know who she was some sister just walked
by and she's like look at this idiot you
know and I was like okay let's do this
and say I mean that doesn't sound like
don't give you much but but for me
that's all it took nothing like being
made fun of why are you having
difficulty or you like wildin out bro
and then yeah and we're about to have
last questions here guys okay the
confidence that you talked about in the
competition goes I'm curious as to
whether the folks on white people is
more of the writers that came up they're
younger than me dance so couple older me
but a bunch of them were younger than me
all right
the only reason I don't want to name
names is not because you asked I'll [ __ ]
them [ __ ] up in a minute
like there's no question about that but
it's also a you start getting into this
personal he-said she-said it gets away
from the issues and that's the way
people tend to boil it down is it like
I'm not interested in personalities like
I'm really interested in some of these
issues you know it's just disappointing
because like you I always hope that like
the young writers are gonna be like
beyond kooky but late modern capitalism
has a really good way of like making
sure everybody's identical you know how
like oh you also like money a lot that's
great
you're real [ __ ] original you know I
mean whatever okay I'm gonna take one
last question because um because oh I'm
gonna take two and try to answer them
both because before you leave I'm just
gonna read you a page so you could leave
with words you know I'm just gonna take
your question yeah I mean I want to but
my characters right now are so mean to
each other but like it really precludes
it and it's also some of the ideas I've
been into though I think they're like
when I get my first real novel done I
think I'll think about these other
things because I feel like that's an
important Shondra I mean when I was a
kid I mean the young adult books really
set me off you know like I could think
of some writers who really had a big
impact on me so I'd like to give a
little back thank you why would you ask
that question anyway what were you
thinking
before you speak to the audience that's
it mostly most directly but all of us
have already been formed a challenge
from institutional uses your random
capitalism you have to take them to
someone younger age yeah it's weird it's
something I learned in Santo Domingo
it's like a word that they don't use too
much in the United States is
simultaneity you know so I'm always like
[ __ ] the either of the or because I
think you're right but I think it's good
to do both get the young people get
everybody every age you know but thank
you and I think you're quite right
I mean and that was the last back there
goes
quite sure but that you were trying to
drive home at 4:30 I just wasn't here
to an elaborate your mixed feelings
[Music]
[Applause]
somebody else want to answer that um you
know what like it's one of those things
where I mean I don't want to get into
like again I don't want to get into
personal issues you know I'd rather I'd
rather just speak I'd rather just speak
like awesome old abstractness that might
connect us in some way you know I mean
again like nobody can tell anybody who
the [ __ ] they can date like that's just
the bottom line
I've never had any issues with that and
I've never worried about that you know
but I do find that people pretend that
when we talk about racism that racism is
a bunch of just discrete little units
that are not connected you know and I
don't see that I see it as a continuum
so the kind of self and I you know I
never accuse anybody of self-hatred
because how would you know you can't
read minds no more than how can they
know because they can't read their
subconscious when somebody tells me that
they have no self hate I have to start
laughing I'm like okay you have total
access to your subconscious I'm like you
need to read foreknown you know like
come on now this books been out for
thirty years but for me what I find
interesting is some very simple things
we're talking about in another class
where there's some very simple patterns
about desire and race and the fact that
they are constant that they're almost
constant they're almost like a law of
physics right there's like we were
joking with another class before I can't
some of the students are here and me and
my boys were when we were coming up we
always noticed that no matter who we
dated they were always lighter skinned
than us and then one of my friends did
this hilarious thing where he took every
single
basketball player and just watching ball
cuz he's an obsessive ball and he just
sat down with a notebook for an entire
season and discovered that like every
single basketball player dates somebody
or is married to someone lighter skin
than them and the fact that it occurs
with such perfection and precision and
without any disruptions of it really
speaks to some wild-ass [ __ ] I mean you
couldn't get that pattern unless you
tried overtime and I guess that's the
sort of stuff I try to critique in my
stories you know whether it has some
relevance to you personally good luck
but I do think that there's a lot of
that there's a lot of what we consider
Beauty is some wild [ __ ] you know it's
like a culturally pre-programmed so I
think it's good to disrupt some of it
whatever I mean I'm like just putting an
intellectual spin on something that my
friends in East Harlem could say in two
seconds you know [ __ ] that like and you
had that question and that's that
and I I was only wearing too wide to be
driving with me celebrate race and and
similar song operate sometimes it seems
like we're an American call center it's
so much the people see start seeing
other people like for example with use
of people's women right and and this
woman and act instead of saying well
thank you I mean I come from a certain
philosophical bent where you know
forgive me but like I don't think others
can could be singled out any more than
they already are you know like I think
gender blind stuff and race blind stuff
is foolish nonsense like our brains are
hard-wired to recognize difference like
they just are you know they are and
that's it I think for me it's not a
problem with recognizing differences is
describing all sorts of negative and
pejorative nonsense to it you know and I
think in the state people try to confuse
those two they're like oh we shouldn't
talk about race because that means that
you know I'm like no I don't mind being
all these multiple things just don't put
negative [ __ ] on it and that's that like
just don't put some old negative [ __ ] on
it and so those of us who want to do
that kind of work I think that that's
the most important thing and people feel
really uncomfortable with that you know
but I'm like you know what you should go
you learn to be humble when you travel
you know and no matter what you say
about yourself
people pick your ass out you know I went
to Japan it was beyond like nothing I
could say about please don't select out
don't see me as a human being like that
wasn't working
and for me the reality is always the
masses you know some old like weird [ __ ]
I mean whenever I walk in African
communities they always crack on me
they're always like you know what are
you bad but I do you know I'm saying so
I don't check out there well I always
check that ugly word Hispanic till they
change it to Latino you know but I mean
again it's like you know you have to do
things for me like I think most of us
have multiple identities
you know like so that I don't mind going
through my list of multiple identities
if you're dumb enough to ask then you're
dumb enough to have to listen you know
so I tend to be like it depends where
the questions coming from you know like
where the questions coming from is
almost as important as the way you
answer it so people will ask me what you
are and I'll if I don't like their
attitude I'll be like what am I the [ __ ]
are you you know like that's the answer
back to you know and but you know the
way I mean I see it most clearly is I'm
like you know it's like a member of the
Dominican diaspora and a member of which
is a portion of the larger African
diaspora I'm an immigrant I'm a Latino
and I come from the you know I'm a man
and I come from a you know the poor
communities urban so you see the list
grows but I don't mind that I think
that's okay all right
I'm just gonna read you guys just one
page I'm sorry you all have to leave go
ahead you guys can go no and I want to
put you on the spot it's just I just
wanted to leave you with just this one
little description from this story the
last story that I'd published and it's
just this little piece on the Dominican
Republic and it's just this this guy
this narrator is just talking about how
much he loves this country which is sort
of nonsense but anyway let me confess I
love Santo Domingo I love coming home to
the guys and the blazers trying to push
little cups of blue God into my hands I
love the plane landing everybody
clapping when the wheels kissed the
runway I love the fact that I'm the only
[ __ ] on board without a Cuban link or a
flapjack of makeup on my face
I love the redhead woman on her way to
meet her daughter she hasn't seen in 11
years the gift she holds in her laps
the bones of Singh's mija has dad dies
now the women whispers the last time I
saw her she could barely speak in
sentences and now she's a woman Hema he
not there I love the bag my mother's
packed [ __ ] for relatives and something
for Magda a gift you give this to her no
matter what happens if this was another
kind of story I'd tell you about the see
what it looked like what it looks like
after it's been forced into the sky
through a blow hole how when I'm driving
in from the airport and see it like this
like shredded silver I know I'm back for
real I tell you how many poor
[ __ ] there are more albinos
more cross-eyed [ __ ] more bigoted
than you'll ever see and the MU head is
only that there and I tell you about the
traffic the entire history of late 20th
century automobiles swarming across
every flat stretch of ground a cosmology
of battered cars battered motorcycles
battered trucks and battered buses and
an equal number of repair shops run by
any idiot with a wrench and I tell you
about the shanties and our no running
water faucets and the samples on the
billboards and the fact that my family
house comes equipped with the ever
reliable latrine and I tell you about my
abuelo and its Compal hands how unhappy
he is that I'm not sticking around and I
tell you about the street where I was
born guy event.the you know how it
hasn't decided yet if it wants to be a
slum or not and how it's been in the
state of indecision for years but that
would make this another kind of story
and I'm having trouble as it is with
this one you'll have to take my word for
it Santo Domingo is Santo Domingo and
let's all pretend we know what goes on
there thank you have a good night you
guys
you